the Joe Rogan experience excited
documentary in Thailand oh did you
really
how is really quite slide oh yeah yeah I
love the the rhythm of the music and you
know it's all cute clued into how they
do their [ __ ] yeah I went up to the
Burmese border the golden triangle
stayed with the hilltribe whoa
I've done a lot of crazy stuff
documentaries what is that how can
someone watch that it's called Veronica
goes and Veronica was the the
organization that I worked for in the
Netherlands the broadcast company is it
available online can someone find
probably bits of it on YouTube Veronica
goes Asia and so it was Thailand I mean
we did a number of things we went into
brothel you know where the girls have
all the numbers and we film there I am
I'm we're going to the longnecks you
know what they have all the rings on and
I think oh this is gonna be great we're
going to see the long necks four and a
half hours and the first to get from
Shanghai to Shanghai up in the north
then a four and a five or five hour bus
drive you said crews right so we're ten
people with producers and everything and
it's like it's gotta be around here and
it's like a big sign almost a neon log
next this way I'm like [ __ ] tourist
trap it really is you know but then we
went up to the hilltribe I'm sure that
they've done it before you know had
crews over but it's only women because
all the men are in the opium Hut and
just completely stoned smoking opium the
women run the whole deal and and they
they chew the betelnut root with uh with
a white paste and it's some kind of
cocoa paste and so of course for the
documentary I tried that not and their
mouths are all red your teeth get
completely red from the beetle nut oh my
god and it's like oh [ __ ] and it's like
like an elevator you got a DMT can be a
little bit of an elevator vibes look
guys I'm [ __ ] hammered spit out all
the rest of it and it stayed with me for
a good 45 minutes the sensation like a
bit DMT but very very light version of
it you know yeah so it's a psychedelic I
guess so I just just you felt this like
you know it felt kind of clear yeah like
oh this is kind of interesting but
alright I'm pretty high
just I don't know I haven't done a lot
of different drugs so I'm not quite sure
but it was interesting but I don't like
the red teeth it's kind of awkward
socially yeah it's a turn-off
what is it maybe the thing the beetle
root non-root night and cocoa paste or
probably coke and some red stuff well
knows what people not root what's what's
in that jazz Jaime do we find out you
got to see the woman's you got you got
to see that you got to see their their
red what of me I think so Veronica goes
America Asia and Caribbean a second 11th
on YouTube oh yeah France got you we
also had to drink Cobra blood yeah it's
kind of sad because first they pissed
the Cobra off and they gonna get the
venom and this is dinner restaurant they
get the venom out of his his sax and
then they slit him open and bleed it
into a glass of alcohol and it's
supposed to be very potent it's about me
that's not you but that's no but that's
this guy's got the teeth of someone who
eats that so he looks very happy yeah so
leave that guy the far right no anyway
do that one who the hell that's a lady
look at her tripping balls
it's happiest [ __ ] anyway but we also
shot a lot of Muay Thai mmm so we went
to like these you know the small like
village fights and just you know kind of
this makeshift ring in the middle of the
jungle and all these people and the
music and just that would be something
that would manage a feudal or magical
you you would enjoy it I think a lot of
twisty and kicky stuff yeah twisting
kicking stuff common like know how to
dance and move your legs around oh I'm
an excellent dancer I bet you are
it's actually my wedding video week so
we got married in May and you know these
days everyone has an iPhone so there's
just video everywhere and I look at
myself dancing I'm like oh my god this
has to stop this video has to be
illuminated I am actually that guy I'm
so bad
let's at least learn to dance some
proper dances together because then I
can keep my posture up my frame right
and that just became a hey this is kind
of fun we are doing this with each other
[Applause]